Sometimes, no matter how great
the rest of the movie is,
there's that one moment you just keep coming
back to. We're covering the biggest pause-worthy
moments in 1990s filmmaking — the funny,
the sexy, and the downright embarrassing.
The classic 1999 science fiction film
The Matrix tells the story of a group
of people who one day realize that the
world they live in is a simulation,
which they then seek to break free from.
Funny enough, a similar thing happened to
a small percentage of viewers during a certain
scene in the film, when a small production error
gave them an unexpected reminder that the film
they were watching was itself also a simulation.
"Do you want to know what it is?"
The moment comes when two of our heroes, Morpheus
and Neo, are going to visit the sage-like figure
known as the Oracle. As they stand in the
hallway outside the door to her apartment,
there's a gorgeously composed insert
shot of Neo's hand reaching out to grab
the reflective metal doorknob. However, in
addition to reflecting Neo and Morpheus,
the doorknob is also reflecting the camera
lens. It's the sort of thing that you probably
won't notice the first few times you watch the
film, but once you see it, you can't unsee it.
That being said, the production team appears to
have come up with a pretty ingenious solution to
hide as much of the camera as possible. They've
covered it with a replica of Morpheus' outfit,
complete with his tie, and they've placed
the camera such a way that it somewhat
blends into Morpheus' torso just behind
it. To be honest, unlike some production
"goofs," we're genuinely impressed by this
bit of old-school movie-making ingenuity.
When Pulp Fiction introduces us to the two hitmen
characters, Jules Winnfield and Vincent Vega,
they're arriving at an apartment building
to retrieve a briefcase that's been stolen
by a small-time criminal named Brett ...
and also to execute Brett and his friends.
However, before they can finish this job, an
unseen attacker emerges from the bathroom,
brandishing a pistol. He
opens fire on the two hitmen,
but once he finishes, we see that
somehow, he hit nothing but air.
There are bullet holes in the wall behind them,
but they themselves are totally unharmed. It's
such an unlikely outcome that Jules eventually
comes to believe that this event was a miracle.
Their lives were spared by God to give them the
chance to repent for all the evil they've done.
"This was divine intervention. You
know what divine intervention is?"
However, some eagle-eyed audience members
noticed a small problem in this scene.
If you pause the film during an earlier shot in
the apartment, before the hidden gunman appears,
you'll see that the bullet holes are already
present in the wall behind Jules and Vincent.
Now clearly, this is just a production
error, but if you want to go really far
down the rabbit hole of weird headcanons,
there's also an alternate explanation. What
if there just happened to be some
bullet holes in that wall already?
What if there was no miracle at all, and the
real reason why Jules and Vincent weren't
harmed by the gunman's shots was because he
accidentally loaded up his gun with blanks?
The 1999 film Fight Club is one of the
most meticulously constructed movies of all
time. And more so than any other
film we're discussing today,
you'll definitely need to pause the
movie if you want to catch some of
this film's hidden Easter eggs because some
of them appear in only a single frame each.
We all remember Tyler Durden's
first iconic scene in the film,
right? While on a plane flight home from
a business trip, our unnamed protagonist
suddenly realizes that there's a strange
man in red sunglasses seated next to him,
played to perfection by Brad Pitt. The
stranger then strikes up a conversation,
and the two discuss airplane safety cards,
homemade napalm, and soap. Although our
narrator doesn't realize it yet, this encounter is
about to change the direction of his life forever.
But what if we told you that this fateful meeting
isn't actually Durden's first appearance in Fight
Club? At several points earlier in the film,
Tyler briefly appears spliced into the film for
only a single frame in each appearance, as though
he's flickering in and out of existence. Those of
you who've already seen the movie can probably
guess why the filmmakers decided to do this,
and for those of you who haven't,
we wouldn't want to spoil any of
this movie's many delightful twists, so
you'll have to check it out for yourselves.
The Star Wars films have always presented
landscapes that are rich with surprising
visual details and secret Easter eggs.
One of the most famous hidden examples
occurs in the 1999 film Star Wars: Episode
I – The Phantom Menace, but it comes and
goes so quickly that you'll probably have
to pause the film to see it for yourself.
The moment occurs midway through the
movie, when the Galactic Senate is
meeting on Coruscant . Among the many aliens
that we see gathered together in this meeting
are a trio of creatures that will
definitely be familiar to most film fans.
They appear to be the same species as the aliens
from the 1982 movie E.T. the Extra-Terrestrial.
This inclusion makes sense once you remember
that the creator of Star Wars, George Lucas,
and the creator of E.T., Steven Spielberg,
are longtime friends and collaborators.
In fact, this is the second crossover
we've seen between these two franchises,
since E.T. the Extra-Terrestrial also had a Star
Wars reference in it. When E.T. is wandering
around on Halloween, he sees a child in a Yoda
costume. E.T. then starts to approach the child,
repeating the word "home" over and over again,
before his human companions drag him away.
The 1997 film Men in Black tells the story of
a secret organization that protects the Earth
from extraterrestrial threats and works
to keep the existence of aliens a secret.
Shortly after our protagonist, Jay,
is recruited into this organization,
he's given a tour of the Men in Black's
extensive underground base. Though there
are many unforgettable sights he encounters
during this sequence, one shot is so dense with
information that audiences had no choice but to
pause the scene if they wanted to take it all in.
Jay comes across a computer terminal that sits
at the base of a massive array of holographic
screens, all displaying real-time footage of
various real-world celebrities who are secretly
aliens. Among the many celebrities displayed on
the screen are Danny DeVito , Al Roker , Sylvester
Stallone, Dionne Warwick, Newt Gingrich, George
Lucas, and even some Men in Blacks filmmakers,
including director Barry Sonnenfeld and
executive producer Steven Spielberg.
Now we've arrived at what's probably the
most hotly debated and controversial moment
we're covering today, a certain infamous "hidden
message" that appears in the sky in The Lion King.
The moment comes midway through the film, when
Simba stands contemplatively at the edge of a
cliff. Overwhelmed by the weight of his past
regrets, he collapses into a tired heap. As
he does so, his weight sends a cloud of dust and
leaves swirling up into the air. For a few frames,
the dust appears to arrange itself into three
letters, interpreted by some viewers as "S-E-X."
Christian groups raised concerns about the moment,
though Disney denied they were actually seeing
anything. Later interviews with animators
reveal that the message was supposed to say
"SFX," a nod to the film's special effects
department. However, for the 2002 IMAX re-release,
and in all subsequent editions of the film,
Disney decided to save itself any more
future headaches by just removing the "letters"
entirely, replacing them with abstract swirls.
The 1999 film Cruel Intentions contains
no shortage of sexy, pause-worthy moments,
but there's one scene in particular
that's gone down in cinema history
as one of the steamiest images
ever captured on celluloid.
When the rich and heartless Kathryn discovers
that Court, her former lover, has left her for
a girl named Cecile , she comes up with a plan for
revenge. Kathryn befriends Cecile without Court's
knowledge and makes it her mission to "corrupt"
Cecile in his eyes by making her sleep with as
many other people as possible. One day, when
the two girls are having a picnic in the park,
Cecile expresses some hesitance about her new
boyfriend, saying that she's never even kissed
a boy before. Kathryn, seeing an opportunity to
help push Cecile towards promiscuity , offers
to show her the ropes by "practicing"
with her. Cecile follows Kathryn's lead,
and after a brief yet passionate make-out, Kathryn
pulls away, leaving Cecile clearly wanting more.
It seems as though audiences
were also left wanting more,
and this iconic kiss became a moment that many
were fond of pausing and/or rewatching over and
over again. It won an MTV Movie Award for Best
Kiss, and has since been parodied many times.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.